hello and welcome to this video against
paranoid ok that's a an interesting move
order to get to the Dutch which I often
answer with this I think black here
doesn't haven't have an easy life even
though it is a playable position it's
not terribly bad or anything but I think
this is kind of interesting to play for
white white gets a very early opening of
the e-file going against this pawn and
see I'm not sure about the theoretical
details but I'm kind of happy with the
position type so um what to do maybe
just get this going to have rook hd1
next okay that's not that I don't mind
Queen switching over here I would
definitely like to trade his bishop on
g7 it's one of his better pieces for
sure okay Queen 285 is probably what is
so
is up to now I can always play a
threesome Queen 85 seems seems quite
likely ok so let's see if I can can
trade this yeah ok so be 595 or taking
95 maybe
be sure I can also take and play Bishop
to d3 attacking them um yeah I'll do
that come on let's speed up attacking
the e7 pawn still not totally clear you
can still go before I wind and I don't I
don't want to play the movies in the
stocks another to a little bit too too
meek to weakening wrong in one word but
not quite sure what I do against before
admittedly rookie 7b takes a three ok so
he decided that he doesn't want to allow
that ok so 925
let's see what i can do if i can it
still has before maybe it still has that
move I can I cannot take it again okay I
I'll take then the ship to be 4i sorry
Bishop to c4 there is d5 take such speed
doesn't look doesn't just look too
brilliant so okay I'm going to take if
you want us to go to see up to ok I
think I'll go with this group b 8 b 3 is
still not so quick that you get
something
95 would be pretty annoying if it hits
but currently Queen 870 so it doesn't
doesn't work immediately and I'm
threatening g5 maybe it just goes King
g7 but then I can go ok I thought that
this is something that you should avoid
one general grounds but maybe I'm too
general hear a voice is a threat after
all ok anyway what what am i doing maybe
this one I actually overlooked it after
a four I don't have root d3a for Bishop
age 58 xp3 I wonder if this is a
possibility no I can take just 60 k
which should be at least a draw at least
should be at least to draw at least
proper english but i think you get the
idea yeah this one huh but i can take
her no i cannot divide take you please
book 2 h8
so back to d3 so that I can threaten
again or is there anything when you
cannot play night at five I can also
maybe play the bishop somewhere else I
but here I'm actually I'm threatening
stuff let's do it it is a repetition of
the night h5 I wonder if I can avoid it
with sensible moose might not be
possible night h5 no he goes back Joe
and why not why not time morning damn
very tough position probably i'm not in
great shape here but it is it is
complicated 55 seconds you can just go
back I guess Jack and pawn takes is a
temple but it's also very weakening I
don't know
you
try to be quick check so what about this
Queen flap doesn't look good between
everyone or something is just okay them
I can take you seven now probably have
to check check check check check check
check check check check 12 seconds check
all right this triquetra now check check
check check check check yeah I am sure
um yeah it was a complicated game just
complicated gym around here I think I
should be in pretty good shape other
structure looks bad for black but maybe
he is just just about active enough it's
it's possible this keep Bishop t2 is a
good move when then play Bishop d3 95
hmm that prevents before this is the
thing you really gets come to play am a
fourth there's a good move by the
computer
if black now takes this is going to be
dangerous very dangerous and here it
probably is okay or even more than okay
it's it's it's very very dangerous try
this and yeah I King Jade a strong no
black ass better I should have played
this one now this this is given a sequel
by the computer very tough yeah yeah I'm
clearly struggling Quincy 3 now would
have been very strong probably this wins
right yeah minus 3 I have no movie
threatening would be 3 and this is also
lost okay so I was lucky and this is not
working at all hahahaha clennie one
shaky know who gate would have one two
check check Jay I'm still lose check
check check check check check check yes
it is a perpetual either way yeah not a
particularly high level game but it was
a it was a good fight let's see what
happens in the next game thanks for
watching